you know what i'm saying free the whole
wide seal man that's my family bro thug
dude gonna broke all them bro don't pay
for my eyes bro
he paid for your eyes yeah i got the
laser [ __ ] on my eyes like i couldn't
even see real for real i had to [ __ ]
that vision he paid for your lasik uh
surgery yeah
yeah yeah but i got i was one of the
whole time i've been out here and took
just like until he went to jail with the
everyday dude i was done every day bro
like real family recently yeah we was
watching the game
this was last year last summer he played
for we watching the game and i couldn't
see the game like tv was like this close
and i'm like hey what's the scope you
like [ __ ] you can't see i'm like hell
no he told his manager like go get go
get his glasses like reading glasses
from from the car i put him on i see how
i'm seeing that he like oh yeah yo i
[ __ ] up like mine
i'm gonna set you with his appointment
tomorrow just beat her and then the
doctors all that i'm talking about
[ __ ] top top top notch
[ __ ] they're like yeah you
ready to i say what you mean ready do
what they like to get your [ __ ] done i'm
like [ __ ]
i need to tell me how much it costs like
no it's already covered jeffrey covered
it
oh yeah man that that man a good man bro
like
it's it's nobody perfect but man that
man was close to perfect in my eyes bro
the way that that man take care of his
people bro and you know what i'm saying
he's still able to be humble and just
how he is bro just it's it's [ __ ] up
to see that [ __ ] happen bro like that
yeah somebody who like employees employs
a lot of people in the city who
obviously gives back and yeah um
except it's just yes it's crazy how did
you end up initially
building that relationship with him duke
i was close with duke and uh
the car dude like
and it was crazy because still been
watching me but when i my when i first
came out a lot of people were scared to
[ __ ] with me because i was tripping like
them guns and all that running from the
police all that all that [ __ ] was real i
ain't abused his ass like did you ever
pay for the police no [ __ ] i definitely
couldn't afford that [ __ ] i was broke
and dirty you [ __ ] [ __ ] we taking off
for real on these [ __ ] but you
know what i'm saying a lot of people was
it was scared to [ __ ] with me because
it's like bro this [ __ ] wow bro like
you know what i'm saying
thugger used to say lil [ __ ] and go
ghost like
like it'll be a video of me and my mom
dudes because everybody everybody know
me and my mom dude's got a good
relationship so we'd be turnt up on ig
to one of my sons and he'd be here
comment and just go go i'd be in thing
like man what the [ __ ] bro and then he
called dukes like hey man tell snap to
pull up the gunner birthday party bro
he like i'm [ __ ] with you and the
more that
i was around him he was teaching me the
game like one thing about me
i'm not no fan [ __ ] like like you know
how [ __ ] are you gonna have
them phones out and all that like i
ain't no [ __ ] if i'm gonna be around a
celebrity i'm quiet hey now i'm trying
to soak the game what can you teach me
what do you see me doing where i can you
know polish up on it you know what i'm
saying to come better and it's like thug
he literally told me like ain't nothing
you could do snack you got everything
that a [ __ ] won't everybody love
you all that usually i get right with
god bro
and when he said it i'm like what the
[ __ ] you mean get right with god like
i'll be praying
like that all that but
i knew what he meant like get right with
god and get your life together my [ __ ]
get your [ __ ] together chill that
dumpster the [ __ ] up yeah yeah when i
did that it was like just doors just got
to open enough for me bro